so the title of this talk is based on a
book chapter I wrote at this point more
than a year ago with my former colleague
Kush varshney at IBM research I used to
work at IBM so we did a selected
overview of both our own work and
broader HCI work that study this topic
of explainable AI and take
human-centered approaches meaning
focusing on people's needs interactions
with a explanation
at that time it was also for me to
reflect on this question of what can
human Center approaches do for
explainable AI and use as a lens to also
reflect on how the HCI and AI Community
can better work together I'm sure that's
a question that you will hear reflect on
a lot so I really appreciate opportunity
to speak here and hopefully having
conversations with all of you I also
realized my answer to this question has
also been driving my own work so today I
will also share some of our very recent
work it's also the first time I talk
about them so please bear with me I want
to start with the definition right what
does explainability mean if you work in
a field you have probably seen a lot of
this kind of discussion was also related
term like interpretability transparency
but I'm going to take a broader and
simple definition that also really
highlights this human-centered nature of
this topic that is explainability is
about making AI understandable by people
with that my focus is often on this AI
system people interact with rather than
model per se and also not just about
explaining AI decision process because
people are interested in broad range of
information how the model was developed
was limitation and of virtually not just
algorithm and technique and today I'm
going to focus more on the interaction
the design side of things
I think I don't need to convince you
that explainability AI expandable AI is
a Hot Topic right even in popular news
it's also in the regulation for example
the gdpr law in Europe uh state that
whenever you have automated decision
process people have rights to meaningful
explanation
is also considered as a principal or a
pillar of responsible AI which is about
developing an ethology that's our
ethical minimize harms to individual and
society and I'd like to see
explainability as the enablerable
foundation for many other principles of
REI right because again explainability
is about understanding and understanding
allows for human scrutinization and if
necessary intervention and with that we
can have better model ensure safety
fairness and help end user to have
better usability appropriate trust and
also have oversight for things like
privacy accountability and things
so where my own work and this HCI work
situated is also a world where the
technical AI Community has made prior
strength so there has already been a
vast collection of xai algorithms
developed
so this is not the focus of this talk
but I want to give kind of one minute
overview I want to highlight that this
many algorithms hundreds if not more
also take various forms even if we
disregard the many different
computational properties right
so there are directly explainable model
some people call glass box model that
follow this relatively human
understandable intuitive process right
things like decision tree rule-based
model linear regression there are also
lots of algorithm uh producing post-hoc
responsibility that is when you already
use this kind of Black Box model say
Jupiter Network or a large Ensemble that
they don't really follow human intuitive
process and you will need another set of
algorithms to generate explanation and
there can be Global explanation for
example
using a simpler model to approximate
these black box models and logic you can
also explain a particular prediction or
decision called local explanation a very
popular explanation is feature
importance essentially highlights for
this instance this input which features
sure is important contribute to the
final decision there are also
counterfactual explanation that answer
this why not why not a different
prediction for example if you change
this feature you'll get a different
prediction this is because people are
often interested different of a more
desirable outcome
another notable Trend here is also there
have been lots of xai toolkits developed
in the industry so these are open source
toolkits people can plug in their own
model data then they can leverage the
state-of-the-art algorithms so in fact
what got me into this topic was uh in
2019 when I was working on IBM I started
working on this toolkit called AIX AI
Expendable t360 and Microsoft has this
version called interpret ml
so with all these two kids lowering the
barrier right I think we're really kind
of on the verge of going to see more and
more real world AI system that has
explanation components and I like to
view This human-centered research also
as a bridging work right bridge this
algorithmic capability to having real
world xci system effective system right
so the system will work in many domains
serve many different users and very
importantly they're going to be built by
practitioners right data scientists
developer designers
I think it's helpful to also take a step
back right to see these technical works
as a producing a toolbox for
practitioners well there are incredibly
interesting technical challenge for
practitioner at another day right what
they need is a good a reliable toolbox
and also know how to use it
so with that metaphor of a toolbox right
summarize these three kinds of
contribution that this HCI work make of
course there are far more than three HCI
contribution but simply a way for me to
Cluster some emerging work
the first one is to navigate this
toolbox right to inform technical
choices by people's expansivity needs
and second one is to assess the toolbox
especially to uncover pitfalls of
existing methods through empirical
studies and with that we can expand the
toolbox right inform new method
conceptual framework for more human
compatible explanation
so I will start from the first one how
to navigate this toolbox one place to
start is to have this kind of top-down
characterization of this space of
people's Expendable techniques then we
can make design recommendations
accordingly
so I think the field has always
recognized that there are many different
stakeholders who need explanation so
many early work try to answer this
question of who are the prototypical
users of xai one group that many early
work focus on are the model developers
who may want explanation to investigate
verify the model and debug model in HCI
as well there are lots of system work in
HCI with community on this kind of
explanatory debugging tool
more recently I think much focus is on
AI decision support system where the
direct users are decision maker right so
this is a real world example of this
kind of
long risk assessment AI that can help a
loan officer to make long decisions
there are many problems you issue with
this kind of system and not get into but
the Hope has been if we give them
explanation we'll be able to help them
make more informed decisions
and there's another group in this kind
of use case is the long applicants right
they're not directly interacting with
the system but their life can be
impacted and they may want explanation
if they're long got rejected to be able
to seek recourse improve future chance
as well as to contact the AI there can
also be business owner who may want
explanation to assess the suitability of
AI for their particular use case and was
a regulatory body who want explanation
to be able to audit for legal ethical
compliance whether it's bias privacy
security
so whenever we want to make this kind of
a top-down characterization right this
granularity level obstruction is the key
question right how do we make actionable
enough recommendation right so recent
work for example this work came out of
MIT by Suresh at all they proposed that
the the Persona is not granular enough
right for example a decision maker at
different usage points may want to
expect different explanation because
they have different goals right when
they're introduced to a system right
they want to assess a compliance when
they're working on a particular case
they may want to take better actions
right so they suggest to consider user
goals and this was so very much aligns
with social science literature of this
kind of functional position or
goal-oriented position right
understanding is a means to an end we
cannot really talk about is the
understanding good enough without
considering what's the end goal
and in my own work I tend to find that
even this goal is not granular enough
right on the other hand uh there has
been HCI literature social science
literature showing that people's precise
explanatory goal can be expressed by
what kind of questions they ask right a
why question what if question or why not
question will need different kinds of
explanation right taking this uh
debugging a model as a Tesco right
people may ask what's the performance is
it good enough how does a model make
decision and why the model make a
particular kind of mistake right so this
paints a rather nuanced picture that
people explaining business needs vary a
lot right depending on the question
depending on their goal knowledge so
having top-down characterization is
useful at the end of day we also need
bottom up user Center approach to
understand for a particular application
for particular Russia what kind of needs
people have so that has been my own work
the focus of my own worker for a couple
of years we wanted to develop a
user-centered design process starting
from understanding people's exponent
needs and use that to drive Technical
and design choice so I'm going to give a
very high level overview today you may
have noticed I always have the reference
at the bottom if you're interested in
checking the detail
so where we started was again in
2019 I was working on this xci toolkit
and I got very interested in this
question of uh we're now putting out
this toolkit do we even know what
practitioner need what kind of
explanation they need to incorporate in
their application so I want to
understand this design space to do that
we decided to interview designer working
on different applications who are also
this kind of bridging role understand
their users
and this kind of question oriented view
was very helpful right because we're
doing a little bit more forward-looking
practitioners are not necessarily using
this algorithm yet so in this instead of
getting into different algorithms we
simply try to understand what kind of
questions their user have so we asked
them in this open-ended fashion we also
prepare this pre-populated question
cards also grounded in what are some
common questions that current techniques
can answer
um and then with that paper uh we try to
make two kinds of contribution one is
that we look at what kind of question
emerge why they emerge in real world
contacts and try to make a relatively
high level design recommendation of how
to address these questions uh we also
did a gap analysis right looking at what
are time questions people tend to ask
but the current technique do not answer
well and make a recommendation for what
kind of future methods may be needed
another contribution we made was this uh
Excel question bank right so we
quote-unquote designer sourced people's
common question and we do content
analysis we cluster them so we have this
set of more than 50 questions that
happening across different a application
that represent this kind of common space
of people's explanity needs and they're
also clustered into these nine different
categories from data output performance
how at a global level why question as
well as multiple counterfacture
questions
now the follow-up work we did is we took
these nine categories of question then
we mapped them to excel techniques that
can answer them the nice thing about
questions also
um they are granular enough you can map
them to specific algorithm and we
particularly focus on ones that are
already available in open source
toolkits because we want practitioners
to use that and by doing that we also
arrived this recommendation in the
middle about what kind of explanation
can answer those questions and also
rounded in technical feasibilities
yes Michael this is really interesting
I'm curious
you've you've mapped from question to
technique and you talked about gaps I
want to have a different kind of Gap so
let's say we have these sets of
techniques that are trying to address
each question between you know how do we
know how closely they actually address
the uncertainties in those questions
like yeah have we crossed those gaps or
are we So my answer is in the next slide
and
yeah so uh before we exercise I want to
order two core idea right uh why is we
are using question as a way to reframe
the technical space rather than think
about is it feature importance
counterfactual we want to reframe it as
what kind of user questions this
algorithm address and that also
encourage practitioners to foreground
understanding user needs rather than
technical feasibility and another idea
is we want to turn a question as a
boundary object to support designers and
data scientists to work to together to
find the right technique and fill the
gaps that Michael was asking right
because designer look at table they
understand what kind of question people
ask what's the underlying needs and data
scientists look at it there's also UI
out to the co-library they can look at a
technical detail so they can make a
decision together
so then we propose this uh
question-driven xai design process which
has four step the first step is you want
to identify your user question and this
can really be just a lightweighted
exercise in your user research introduce
the AI system get people's reaction and
follow by asking what kind of questions
you have right you want to gather the
question analyze the question identify
priorities for example what questions
many people ask and the third step is
where the designer and data scientist
needs to sit down together find the
right solution they can use that table
as a reference but importantly they have
to consider their user their model their
data right with that data scientists can
Implement those technique and designer
can create a design based on the
technique they chose and we emphasize it
must be also be an iterative process
so while I was at IBM we did a lot of
work really trying to encourage product
teams to adopt this process right so one
example here is so this is a
collaboration with Watson Health they're
developing this Healthcare analysis
event prediction system meaning a doctor
doing like a discharge the system can
tell them this patients have a high risk
of unplanned hospitalization and they
need to design the care plan accordingly
so we started with the process of
interviewing doctor Gathering their
questions for example everyone asked the
why question why this patient have this
high risk also lots of daughter kind
someone surprisingly are interested in
the data because they want to know if
the data aligns with their patient
population and you can see the design we
created on the right has a clear
correspondence with the questions we
collected
so that's a very high level overview I
do want to move to the second part of my
talk which is something uh I'm a more
excited these days but I want to warn
you things are going to take a downturn
from here so I want to move to the
second type of contribution is that
human Center approaches empirical
studies can help us uncover pitfalls
right so there has been a lot of
excitement right including system work
incorporating those algorithms but today
I want to draw your attention to some
hidden risk of xai method that are
discovered by empirical studies and I
want to particularly focus on this use
case of decision support
the general setup of AI decision support
is a human make a decision for a case
but now we're introducing a model into
the middle the model is making a
prediction
and that essentially turned as a human
decision Maker's task into a Reliance
decision right do you take the model
prediction rely on it or you do
something else and whether this Reliance
is appropriate depending on whether the
model prediction is appropriate
so there has also been the hope that
explanation can help if you add
explanation together with the prediction
then people can gain more insights about
model decision then that help them to
have more appropriate Reliance and
ultimately better decision outcome
but the reality is quite opposite right
so we had this paper published at fact
2020 together with my former colleague
infon Zhang and Rachel Bellamy so we did
this control experiment where we use
this kind of a semi-toy decision task
where we give you someone's profile and
ask you to judge if this person belongs
to a high or low income group and then
we use this very basic feature
importance explanation tells you for
this profile which feature indicates a
high income which feature indicator low
income and that's how overall I think
this person belongs to a high income
group
what we find out showing explanation
versus not showing explanation just
showing the prediction actually reduce
the decision performance and the reason
is when the model is uncertain or when
even the model is wrong showing
explanation actually increase people's
tendency to blindly follow the model so
that's what's called over reliance
and we're not the only one finding this
problem there has been follow-up work
also uh not just in this kind of
decision support uh use case right so
for example my MSR colleague with the
former intern card at all they look at
this kind of debugging use case data
scientists use this kind of
visualization Excel visualization they
also find evidence that this lead to
overconfidence that model is ready for
deployment
some study even find that placerbic
explanation without actually giving you
useful information about the model can
increase Trust
so I want to quote that over Reliance on
AI is a serious problem it's not just uh
this is one-off arrows right there can
lead so many Downstream harms as well
and long-term issues such as this
scaling and also problem like how do we
assign blame how do we assign
accountability right so that's that's a
concerning Pitfall
um so many recent work try to explain
this phenomenon why we have these people
many from this aspect of lacking
cognitive engagement that people do not
really carefully examine or Reason about
explanation right either because they
have trouble understanding it or they're
not motivated enough to do so and this
is not really because participants
didn't care about the task right for
example halina's paper hi halina shows
that people may conscious choose not to
engage with explanation if they perceive
the quality of course a quality burden
is too high and does not really justify
the benefit of engaging with explanation
so this is uh this kind of
interpretation is largely based on this
kind of a dual qualitative process right
so you may have read the book thinking
fast and slow that one in human process
information we follow two kinds of
system
uh there is this system to slow thinking
that you try to gather information try
to make a rational judgment but people
often also resort to the system one fast
Thinking by invoking Cardiff heuristic
or rule of thumb from their experience
right so this point to a blind spot in
xci work that we seem to make this
underlying assumption that their only
ideal users will carefully engage with
explanation and able to understand it
but in reality if you're actually more
likely to resort to this system one
thinking and in some of our work we find
evidence that people tend to have
positive heuristics associated with
explanation I think this kind of overall
framing of expandable AI is such a good
thing is is also adding to that right we
find that people tend to superficially
associate being explainable to being
trustworthy being capable and that leads
to over are optimistic and over-reliance
as well
so including myself I have been using
this kind of framing to explain this
over-reliance phenomena but at the back
of my head I always have this a little
bit discomfort of
lacking quality engagement are we
blaming the user right is it actually
inherent limit to what an xci method can
do
so I think it would be helpful to get a
bit more principled understanding of
what are people doing with explanation
I'm going to borrow some concept and
terminology from this work coming out of
Channel 10's Lab at University of
Chicago who is also my long-term
collaborator and the lead author is
piuchusion and Cha-Cha Chen
so it's a theoretical paper that they
differentiate model decision boundary
which is how the model make decision how
the model assign label and test decision
boundary which is how the decision
should be made
what matters is a human have certain
intuition about task decision boundary
right someone who are Highly Educated
tend to make more income right so
explanation itself at least this kind of
future importance explanation can only
give you information about the model
decision boundary
but while you are using it you are
constantly comparing that to your own
intuition about the tax decision
boundary and the contrast where is where
you can detect model errors
and I would go a step further and
arguing that this kind of contrast
between model decision boundary and your
intuition happens to almost all these
different use cases we talk about right
and it makes a difference whether you
take the position uh the is the human no
more than AI if you assume human knows
more than AI these are the kind of human
oversight use case you want to detect
bugs you want to detect compliance issue
or context model through explanation
if you assume the AI knows more than the
human that's the kind of AI Insight use
case you want to gain domain knowledge
or scientific discovery from explanation
but the interesting thing is where do we
fade decision support right there seems
to be a inherent tension here that when
we talk about AI decision support we
want humans to learn something new to
make better decisions but we also want
human to have this oversight to be able
to override AI so what is exactly
happening here and what is this
interplay between human intuition and AI
output so to answer that question uh
last summer we did this project with our
intern Valerie Chan who is PhD student
at CMU is also a joint project with Jane
woodmanville and gargan pencil so we did
an experiment to look at this
decision-making process again we use the
fairly simple decision task one is again
this income guessing kind of task
another is we give you this someone's
online biography and you can get
someone's profession so one is a tabular
data and router is a is a tax data right
so there's nothing new about the task
they have been used by prior HCI studies
because these are accessible tasks and
honestly also the training data is using
to get but what we did differently is we
went to this good old psychology HTM
method we ask people to think a lot then
we look at their think aloud data the
trace to understand what is exactly
going on the decision making process
we also want you to look Beyond this
kind of future importance explanation
and another categories of explanation
called example based right there are
different forms of example based
explanation but we did something very
simple we just show people
similar instance using nearest neighbor
to find a similar instance we show
people the model's prediction as well as
the ground truth so you may argue this
is not really about a model decision
process if you adopt this very narrow
definition explanation but the argument
has been that they give people idea the
model's decision boundary and I would
argue they also give information about
the task boundary because the ground
truth right
so what we find is
again feature-based explanation very
consistent with the other work we talk
about is they led to over-reliance so
when the model is wrong it actually
decrease people's performance accuracy
and overall we did not see human AI
joint decision over perform AI along our
human alone
but when we look at example-based
explanation right we find that they do
not have this over Reliance problem they
increase people's performance when the
model is right and overall we observe
this complementary complementary
performance that this joined outcome
over perform human or AI along you'll be
surprised actually pretty rare in this
kind of a study to observe this
complementary performance
so what matters is we want to understand
what exactly happening right I part is
our frustration is there has been lots
of work on human AI Reliance or trust
but we actually don't know how this
appropriate Reliance human override AI
actually happen
so we look at this think aloud data
right we summarize this uh three we call
pathway for people to override AI
the first one is when the human already
have a strong intuition about decision
outcome and the outcome is different
from AI prediction the interesting thing
is we observe when people have a strong
intuition they actually less likely to
engage carefully with the explanation
and also coming back to the question of
is the decision support about human
oversight or AI insight and I think
that's actually both and it really is a
case-by-case basis and I also point to
like this kind of decision support we
need to consider uh different needs as
at a case level
and the pathway true is quite similar to
that Chen adoles paper is people apply
intuition about the features to reason
about negative evidence in explanation
whether they disagree with how the model
weighs or they disagree whether that is
actually similar how the instance should
go
there's also a third path is people try
to recognize AI limitation
whether it's at a global level they
think oh AI is not good at this kind of
case because biases or they try to
recognize for this decision it's an
ambivalent decision they should not rely
on it
now let's look at the two explanation
right how they make a difference
very interesting we find that when
people are given this feature-based
explanation they are much more likely to
acknowledge they don't know they don't
have a strong intuition
one of the reason is
this actually visually quite
overwhelming right it's overlaid on the
instance where it's a visualization they
disrupt People's Natural intuition
process while with example based people
can't just focus on the case itself
before moving on to other information
another reason is if we look at a second
pathway we find that people actually
have a lot of difficulty to reason about
explanation one main issue is that human
intuition tends to be qualitative we may
recognize oh this is a relevant feature
these are relevant keywords but we may
not know like this word should be
touches darker than the other word where
this feature should be 20 more and when
people are confronted with that kind of
Quantified information they tend to feel
confused and many of them choose to
acknowledge they don't know and delegate
to AI uh the interesting thing with
example base here is also uh it actually
has this benefit allowing people to form
new intuition uh for example they look
at example they say oh professors tend
to publish at this kind of Journal so
they have this new intuition about
future through this kind of inductive
reasoning because example bringing
additional contacts
and if you look at a path three it's
also interesting is uh people try to
from explanation also try to recognize
this unreliability signal through a
certain kind of pattern right for
feature sorry for example based it's
very obvious that is when the model
makes mistake on similar instance they
tend to actually correlate with arrow
especially when the model make a mistake
on both examples but the nice thing is
it's a very strong signal people really
gravitate towards that in contrast
feature-based in theory right they have
a signal that is if the model sees
feature importance go in both sides that
is a very ambivalent decision
but people don't recognize that only
very few participants recognize that as
a signal
so I think that kind of uh go ahead oh
yeah sorry I
I
um because I I liked something that you
said which is like feature-based
explanations seem to be more like
quantitative whereas like an example
based or more qualitative like you're
trying to figure out what the patterns
are
um do you know like because I think
maybe like in my head maybe the
quantitative elements could be more
useful for like generalizability maybe
that's why we try to give it to people
like this is a Formula that you can
follow to like predict the future like
predictions that an AI would make
um do you know whether like
if there's a difference between these
two and like how people are able to then
predict or project like the ai's
abilities like in the future right right
yeah that's a cool question so this is
not to deny like a feature importance is
not uh useful at all right I think
they're at least for some kind of user
they might not be compatible with how
people reason but I also think there is
a space for design solution to make them
more compatible right you can imagine
one way is we don't start with showing
you super qualified super detailed
information we can tell you what are the
top features if you want to dig deeper
you can choose to look at it so that's
just just one example but I think the
the last thing is there's certain
incompatibility and we need to kind of
bridge that that part of Gap
so yeah so I think the results kind of
really resonates with
um some reflection we had in that book
chapter about this root course of this
XI Pitfall right which can be again
broadly applied to AI that we put out
some AI technology then they have this
kind of a hidden risk
one reason is that the output May
disconnect with people's quality process
right we don't consider due quality
process we don't realize this feature
importance is actually incompatible with
how people reason
but I think there's a deeper issue here
is that algorithm development do not
take into account this diverse
Downstream usage context right this is
not to blame individual users and
individual researchers right when they
don't have this established practice or
scaffold when AI researcher develop
algorithm they may think about use case
that they themselves are familiar with
such as debugging instead of what the
other use cases we talk about like
decision support auditing biases right
so that need to kind of blind spot of
important criteria that people care in
different Downstream use case that are
not going into this technology
development right for example people
care about detecting arrows why why
aren't we optimizing or at least
evaluating with that right
so with that reflection I want to move
to the third part is how HCI approaches
can expand the toolbox for that question
today I want to plug some of our most
recent work which I also think is our
effort to fill these two sets of
disconnect
one line of work I'm excited about is to
make explanation more human compatible
by drawing inspiration from Human
communication where I think the primary
contribution are Frameworks or ways to
rethink how we have explanation rather
than algorithm per se
so probably right there has been
criticism around the fact that current
AI explanation have significant gaps
with how humans plan
and the best place to read about it is
this Tim Miller's paper where he did
this very nice overview survey of social
science literature getting into what are
some fundamental properties of human
explanation today I want to focus on the
the bottom two which is human
explanations are selective and when
being selected we're also tailoring to
the recipients right what do I mean by
selective right taking a example there
is a car accident and usually there can
be dozens of events leading to that
accent
but when you expand you are not going to
talk about everything you are going to
be selective
and social science leader is showing
that this selection is not arbitrary
there are common heuristics we follow
and that also depend on what kind of
goals we have right if someone is
interested in this fact of the damaging
the damage is surprising then you're
going to pick courses that are most
relevant to that that the speed is very
high
if you talk to a police who wants to
diagnose the courses the problem now you
likely to pick what's the most abnormal
event like this car made a sudden name
change
if you want to give a lesson to your kid
you may pick what's the most changeable
that really should not have happened
that the driver is drunk
so
we want to mimic this kind of a
selectivity of human explanation so this
joint work with tranhao 10 and the
little authors are Vivian Lai iming
Zhang and Chacha Chen so we proposed
this General framework to produce
selective explanation and is to augment
existing explanations so take any kind
of feature important explanation rather
than showing you all the feature
information we want to select ones that
you would believe to be relevant
abnormal or changeable depending on the
selective goal right and how do we get
there is we want to learn about your
belief of relevance abnormal or
changeability by your input your
annotation on a small sample we in this
work we propose also different ways to
get that kind of input but I want to
walk you through just an instantiation
right
so this is a task that the model is
doing this sentiment Judgment of movie
review
and then you have this kind of
feature-based explanation you can
generate from any kind of feature
importance algorithm that tell you the
the models think this is a positive
movie because it picked up this positive
keywords uh why is that it's still
visually overwhelming and I would also
say it's disruptive you might end up get
hung up on some relatively trivial thing
like why the model picks up Western as a
positive indicator
so we want to generate selective
explanation by learning your belief of
what is relevant to movie sentiment task
we can do that by critique based
feedback we show you example we show you
model explanation and you can tell me
which one you think is relevant or
irrelevant to movie sentiment what we
can get from open-ended feedback we give
you sample you tell us which keywords
you consider as as relevant
and we just do a small sample say 10
movie review then we train a prediction
model
to predict in unseen new instance which
keywords align with your relevance
belief
model tailored for individuals are you
learning a single model across good
framework we do consider
different ways to get this input you can
get at individual level you can get a
group of similar users to allocate it so
both are fine we actually did two sets
of experiments one with your own input
one with similar input you that's the
details in the paper yeah
and then we use that to augment the
explanation right so we take this raw
explanation we predict whether the words
align with your relevance belief if it
does not align with grave out the words
so we're essentially saying this is what
the model picked up but these words
you're going to think them irrelevant
anyway so don't look at them just look
at see the model picked up the keywords
are pretty good
so that we did a control experiment We
compare this experiment condition with
Selective explanation and the raw
explanation the unselected one and we
find several benefits so the first two
are more related to people's subjective
perception we find that they improve
people's subjective understanding
because the selective explanation is
sponsor they're clearer they're easier
to understand so people feel they
understand better
and the second one uh interesting we
also find that improve people's
perceived useness of the AI but back to
Michael's question we only find that in
a condition when people provide their
own input so that really attributes you
um the reason is because now I can my my
own input augmented AI output and I end
up liking the AI better which I find
interesting
um the last one I think is most
promising we also find selective
expansion improved decision performance
and reduce over-reliance so let's look
at one example right so this is an
example where the model made a mistake
the ground truth is a positive review
but a I think is negative if you look at
the the original explanation right the
reason is the model picked some up some
questionable negative words right it
thinks uh stop words and also the word
depriving to be indicator of a negative
sentiment which is questionable that's
true for movie sentiment judgment
what about what's the selective
explanation is Yin those questionable
words are grayed out and what's left is
actually more consistent with the ground
truth now the the strongest word is the
greatest I want to point out here that
this is because the gray out can be seen
as a form this contrast we talk about
right it's contrast of what the models
think the decision boundary what the
model think is relevant and this human
intuition what the human think is
irrelevant and I want to emphasize that
this work because in this task sentiment
judgment human can provide reasonably
good intuition so that is gray out to
provide reasonably good signal of motor
arrow and in fact if we look at the the
percentage of highlights we can see that
with a selective explanation the
highlights is actually
more aligned with the ground truth we
increase the percentage that align with
the grounders so now people look at
selective explanation if they pay
attention to the highlights they're
actually more likely to get it right
rather than following the AI prediction
so that explains
um this will observe this improved
performance
um so those are some promising results I
hope that pique your interest to read
the paper I love to hear your feedback I
also hope this study kind of showcased
the opportunity as well as interesting
nuances when you try to operationalize
the kind of a human communication
Behavior into computational interaction
um I have a few minutes I I want to
spend a few minutes to briefly touch on
this work
um so this is a line work I'm excited
about coming back to this disconnect
second disconnect of uh Downstream use
case when AI researchers develop
algorithms right I think one place to
close the gap is to bring more insights
bullying more consideration of this
Downstream use case a quick usage
informed evaluation and I also think
this where HCI research can make
valuable contribution by bringing our
understanding of Downstream use case
so we have this paper
um published at hcom and of last year uh
so we proposed this concept of
contextualized evaluation
so we're motivated by this observation
of a gap
that in the AI Community there has been
dozens of
evaluation criteria or construct
proposed right you can use them either
for user study evaluation or developing
computational metrics for example lots
of work trying to quantify the
explanation faithfulness compactness
robustness and things like that but on
the other side right as I discussed in
the beginning HCI were trying to point
out that there are different Downstream
use case people have different goals
they want to achieve with explanation
so our goal is to be able to explicitly
consider this context dependency right
in what kind of use case which
evaluation criteria matter
so I think this kind of thinking uh can
be broadly applied to whenever we
develop AI technology has diverse
Downstream use case right but in my mind
in these days is focus is kind of a
quote-unquote general purpose large
model right I think this has some
similarity with uh the recent evaluation
work come out of Stanford that when you
evaluate a large language model you want
to First articulate a scenario and that
guide your choice of evaluation metrics
but what matters here is also I think
empirical study can help us really to
get to that context dependency and this
helps with responsible research right
help AI researcher articulate which
Downstream use case this explanation is
good for and also help practitioners
right when they work on a particular use
case they know what to evaluate what to
choose for
so I think what matter is this kind of a
high level idea the the methodology is
actually pretty straightforward I would
say a little oversimplify we use this
kind of scenario based survey we recruit
both axial experts and also crowd worker
as uh this uh Target user of an
application then we show people scenario
this is a AI application and this is a
scenario of you are using explanation to
achieve a certain goal and we developed
this scenario by serving HCI literature
looking at those taxonomy of use case
taxonomy of user goals and we just ask
participants in this scenario how do you
rate the importance of different
evaluation criteria
so the details are in the paper so we
can get this kind of rank right how do
we rank this evaluation criteria for
different kinds of use case why is they
give you this nuanced understanding of
what evaluation criteria matter for what
a use case and you look through them
also from participants qualitative
comments that give you understanding of
why and another point is also give us
this critical understanding of what
people care about and where are the gaps
in the current practice right for
example again for decision support
people care about this unreliability
slash you uncertainty communication but
we don't have a good metric to evaluate
that
so
um I'd like to conclude my talk with
some personal lessons learned from uh
working in this in between space of
algorithms and user experience
especially by working close to
practitioners right
one is I think it's useful to have this
kind of human-centered reframing of
technical space right to be able to
articulate four technique what kind of
Downstream use case they serve what user
needs what user values they serve and it
was also helpful to develop means to
help AI researchers to articulate that
as well and second is we want to
facilitate responsible use of technology
I think especially with AI sometimes the
research advancement is detached from
specific use case and we need to
carefully examine what are the pitiful
what are limitations what are the
mismatch of assumption that will also
help practitioners to develop technology
in a more responsible way and third one
is it sounds obvious that I think HDI
contribution is also about expand
practitioners took box with design tool
I think the issue is sometimes when
people talk about AI they mix the model
and application but there's a whole
design space a lot of things can happen
that that practitioner can really take
advantage of
uh and lastly I think uh is as HCI
researchers I think we have a
responsibility to engage with deployment
contacts and people leave the experience
and bring that back into technology
development and criticism is not enough
it's also about how we formalize
operationalize human needs as
computational or evaluation framework
and with that I want to thank you for
your attention I want to thank my hcxai
community and I'm happy to take
questions
thank you
all right we've got a few minutes at
folks want to engage
[Music]
hi um I was curious about your
experiment where you had uh explainable
examples instead of using the feature
based is that for is that in terms of
you're trying to do it for each model
then they would do it or is that for
every time the AI makes a prediction
because I'm curious about the time that
it would take for them to read through
all of the examples and if you're say
doing content moderation or something
like that where you have tons is it
these board you expect them to be able
to do those uh the examples each time
yeah yeah that's a great question I
think there are two separate thing one
is a
clarify like
experiment our local explanation so
everything is for that particular
prediction right so that the feature for
that prediction for example for that
prediction but you touch on another more
important topic is this kind of uh uh
calculative cause and engagement of that
I think that's General attention with
explanation is um it can be overwhelming
take additional costs again with a with
a helleness paper right so
um I do think part of the the example
based explanation reduce costs come from
some of the signals are very easy to
recognize you don't necessarily have to
read a detail you can look at whether
the model makes mistake on those
examples so that is actually I would say
a lower cost signal that help you to
detect model without necessarily read
the content but you also have the choice
to make deeper engagement to to reason
about is this example who actually
actually close or where this
differential feature should go so they
give you this kind of choice but that's
a that's a excellent question thank you
thank you
we can chat later but I'm happy to ask
here
one of the things that you've elicited
through
the one of the project that you were
describing was essentially feedback on
the explanation model itself right like
that you're learning that the following
features of explanation are not useful
but it's not just that they're it seemed
like from the examples you were giving
it's not just that they were
not useful explanations it's that they
were actually
not good for the model to be paying
attention to at all so it does raise the
question of why are we using that to
improve the explanation rather than just
to provide that as feedback for the
model yeah
like if you subtract that out of the
model then maybe the explanation would
have made more sense right right that's
a that's a really good question I think
uh we definitely struggle with the
question should it improve the
explanation or should we improve the
model right I think there are use cases
you just can't improve the model you
take a black box model then that's
that's the only thing you can do right
but there has been also been work around
uh using human rationale as training
signal itself to improve the model I
think a reasonable follow-up work we do
is probably use that as a model training
signal and see whether that improved the
model I think that's definitely
something we should do but that's that's
an excellent point I don't I don't have
a clear answer like which way will go
better but there are situations we just
have to use it to augment explanation I
mean if I were to push back on myself
one argument you could give is that the
thing that would make me better making
decisions does not necessarily make me
bet a better teacher yeah right if I'm
trying to explain something that doesn't
mean like how I do and how I explain
might be totally different skills yeah
okay the other question which is pro
you're probably expecting but just sort
of given recent movement
where does all this sit relative to
generative models right like where where
are we where we ought to go you know
this was mostly focused on
discriminative models and where there's
explicit features and so on yeah yeah
thanks for that question and uh I
actually have a slice I didn't have time
to attach on today but I can talk more
uh so I think again I think there's a
human-centered perspective one important
is we have to consider and go we cannot
talk about explanation without
articulate what's the end goal right so
I think uh with this large general
purpose model it's become even harder to
articulate we don't even know what are
the different use case
um so I think explanation will be useful
but we need to look broader than
algorithmic explanation we need to think
in terms of transparency right for
example one use case that I didn't have
time to touch on today we have these two
Kai paper coming out actually a
collaboration with Harry here so I'm
very interested in this space of this
question of a responsible use right you
have this general purpose
where should I use it especially for
designers right and in this kind of use
case I don't necessarily think the
answer lies in algorithmic explanation
tell me with this input how I got that
output right what I'm interested is what
is this design material what is boundary
right what's the capability and where
things break
so in that kind of use case I think this
concept of model interrogation you
mentioned in the beginning is more
useful you won't give people tool to
help them to see where things might
break and that will be more useful than
explanation so so that's just an example
why I feel like
um we need to look Beyond algorithm
explanation and think about what's the
end goal people want to achieve and we
need to have this broad set of how do we
how people understand them better
that's my answer thank you
so going back to that example where
there's kind of the loop between people
getting the explanations and then kind
of critiquing which parts are useful and
then that informing future explanations
I'm curious about
how that could be done for problems
where people have a harder time making
those decisions so for like positive or
negative movie reviews that's something
that like that's a human task that's
like easy to do but sometimes we're
using models for things that are like
not easy to do for people is are there
ways to still extract the insights from
people about like what sort of
explanations are useful even for those
kind of more opaque tasks yeah yeah
that's a great question and it really
gets to this um I think a fundamental
problem when we study human AI decision
making that we're mixing different kinds
of decision support right like a a movie
sentiment review then human has certain
knowledge but you can also have a domain
that human actually want to gain
complete gain Insight from the AI right
so um yeah I think a lot of benefit we
see in that experiment comes from
because that task human can give
reasonably good intuition right so that
may not generalize
to the other kinds of tasks but in our
framework we did propose that uh in that
kind of task maybe it's more useful to
get input from domain experts you get
that from domain expert once and then
you propagate that and that may help
people who are not a domain experts to
make better decisions okay thanks for
the question
you landed that exactly on time
[Applause]